also tonight while many on the left are
suddenly eager to denounce andrew cuomo
others just can't shake their deep
affection for the new york and battle
governor today a likely teary-eyed alec
baldwin bravely tweeting regardless of
what you think of cuomo this is a tragic
day
party politics in this country draw
ambitious but ultimately isolated even
socially maladjusted men and women who
given the current cancer culture will
likely have their shortcomings exposed
and magnified i wonder if alec baldwin
would offer a similar level of
compassion for donald trump or any
republican just asking a question now
meanwhile don't call it a comeback we
have nbc's chuck todd is already
plotting governor cuomo's return to
public life
thinks it can happen take a look
part of the punishment if he was
convicted in an impeachment trial would
have been no longer be able to serve in
office in the state of new york
and
you know i think a cuomo believes you
can go and live another day his career
was either permanently over or
almost permanently over and he chose the
path of almost permanently over right
the resignation gives him you know we
know the way our world works
um it's amazing the people we've seen
make political comebacks
you know you can't ever rule it out
i think elliot spitzer didn't get a job
on fake news cnn i don't remember anyway
not to be outdone the face of the
washington post jennifer rubin
sidestepped cuomo's resignation
completely
exclaiming that new york is about to
have its first woman governor ever now
her name is kathy hokel new york's
lieutenant governor and she will take
over for cuomo in two weeks here with
reaction fox news senior meteorologist
janis dean she is tirelessly as all of
you know work to hold andrew cuomo
accountable ever since her own in-laws
that's right
father and mother-in-law died from
covert 19 in this nursing home scandal
along with fox news contributor joe
concha fox news contributor former
arkansas governor
mike huckabee janice we'll start with
you you were surprised then you actually
made the comment that you never thought
this day would happen you were in a
state of shock
and
um you thought he was he was it was some
divine intervention and he was going to
blame everybody else again today
i really did i thought he was going to
follow his own playbook which is blame
blame blame the new york post and fox
news and god mother nature the women
not him of course just a
misunderstanding from these women who he
groped but that's what i thought he was
going to do today and then he
started to say well you know i want new
yorkers to be tough and i love new
yorkers and i love this state so i think
instead of an impeachment i'm going to
resign and i was shocked but i'll tell
you this
yesterday we had a memorial for my
in-laws finally after a year and a half
of not being able to have a wake or a
funeral or last rites or to see them
before they died and we had it at sean's
father's firehouse 323 for 23 years he
was a firefighter and
my husband said to me you know wouldn't
it be interesting if the governor
resigned today and you know we thought
about it and it happened today but i'm
grateful you know why because yesterday
it was about my in-laws and i didn't
want it to be on about andrew cuomo
interesting points um governor as you
look at this
from not just a political standpoint but
the the legal case that greg jarrett
very articulately laid out on a whole
series of issues
that to me is the vulnerability now of
andrew cuomo i i knew it was pretty
inevitable when every democrat in new
york condemned him and walked away from
him
i'm told that pretty much he didn't have
any friends by the end of this but he
didn't have many friends for years
apparently the question is do you do you
see the department of justice doing
their job do you think the people in new
york are capable
of equal justice and application of our
laws
let me first of all just say to janice
i'm so glad that there has been at least
a piece of justice not full justice but
a piece of it even though it has not
been adjudicated yet about the nursing
home deaths and the cover-up of the
nursing home deaths uh thank god for
janis dean and her relentless pursuit of
the truth and without her i don't think
this day would have happened
uh it's really by the way governor let
me let me just add to that i want to i
want to say i agree with you
but i will tell you this we have to get
to the nursing home issue we have this
has to be got another bottom up
so i take the floor
and i think there's there's more than
the nursing home issue there's also uh
did his staff help write that book for
which he was paid over five million
dollars that's a a major scandal
there's a lot of things and i don't
think the national department of justice
at the washington level will do anything
i just don't think joe biden's doj is
going to pursue him but here's what i
think might happen it may happen in new
york between the legislature and the
attorney general and here's why andrew
cuomo has spent years making enemies
they were afraid to fight back
but he pretty much just rained on
everybody's parade he was a bully and
that's why he got away with this with
women so long if in fact everything they
said is true
because they were afraid afraid of him
well they're not anymore and nobody is
none of the legislators are afraid of
him
the other officials and this idea that
he may come back that's nonsense
there's a silver bullet in him a stake
in the heart this this is a vampire that
will not
come back out at night and i think there
could be some serious repercussions that
will happen in new york but not
at the federal level unfortunately joe
what's your take on it
well let me first condemn janis dean as
well she was a lone vessel a year ago
more than a year ago in the spring of
2020 talking about the nursing home
scandal when very few in media would and
i'm old enough to remember a
spokesperson for andrew cuomo going
after janice dean directly somebody who
lost her in-laws
saying that oh stick to the weather
please well guess who's getting the last
laugh now so janice great job in
sticking with that when very few in this
business would do that and standing up
for your principles and knowing what was
right um as for chuck todd uh you know
who's only the political director of nbc
news and the moderator of meet the press
how could he make this statement you
know sober quote cuomo eventually did
something that maybe over time will at
least give him an opening to maybe not
be a full pariah say in three four or
five years and perhaps he can make a
comeback
an opening where exactly as president of
the raccoon lodge the governor of the
nipple rings for seniors association
because to the governor's quote point
before andrew cuomo pre-2020 very few
political allies in the first place
there's still an ongoing investigation
to the nursing home scandal that we
talked about and sexual harassment
allegations from 11 women just don't
vanish they're quite sticky but chuck
todd says a comeback could happen that
sound you just heard sean that's the
great tim russert rolling over in his
grave again you're not going to see
andrew cuomo running and winning
anything ever again it just can't happen
given everything that we just laid out
he very well be charged criminally by
the time this is all done
janice i think it's appropriate we give
you the last word um and i do strong i
like what the governor said and joe said
it's
um you still lost your in-laws
you know you you know and what you went
through even this week sounds awful my
question is what was your reaction to
joe biden saying hell of a job he did
because that kind of came out of nowhere
to me
i thought it was a tape from last year
when he was you know wanting cuomo to be
his ag i couldn't believe that it was
from today so i would like uh president
joe biden or jen sake to give me a call
and i'll give them a rundown of all the
things this governor did wrong and that
led to the deaths of thousands of
seniors and maybe if they listen to that
they might have a different opinion
tens of thousands when we look at the
four states that followed his lead he
was first then you have pennsylvania and
new jersey and michigan people died
needlessly including your in-laws
uh thank you all hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else